[Music]
the golden knights announced they will
may
at least they will miss at least two
more games due to covid protocol now the
team will not be making the next road
trip
to arizona john treach has the latest on
the quarantined hockey team john
that's right kirsten if team management
could legally seal the players and
coaches and vaccinate a bubble wrap
until june i
don't think they'd hesitate but there
are limitations after all the golden
knights are feeling the burden of the
pandemic spread four people in protocol
and now three games postponed the good
news there are no new
knights players on the nhl coveted list
the bad news the league has postponed
the next two games on february 1st and
third versus the sharks
the games were scheduled to be played in
arizona but the nhl says they will try
to reschedule them when
the sharks are allowed to play in their
california arena
golden knights defenseman alex
petrangelo is the only player on the
list and he says he is not
experiencing symptoms beyond keeping
players and families safe another
unsolved mystery is if and when they are
going to make up
all of these missed games the golden
knights are faced with the challenge of
corkscrewing makeup dates into an
already densely scheduled
calendar of games and so we shall see